[موسيقى]
مرحبا تستقبل الدراما المصريه هذا العام
العديد من النجوم العرب حيث يمثل في معظم
الاعمال النجم او اثنين واحيانا اكثر في
المسلسل لتكون قصته مصريه وانتاج مصري
وربما تم تصويره بالكامل في مصر فكيف
ينعكس هذا الامر على العمل وعلى الفنان
وما مدى اهميته
الفنانين السوريين ولا لبنانيين ولا
بشتغلوا بمصر ولا التوانسه يعني ما في هذا
الموضوع صار اخر كم سنه بينحكى فيه بالاول
ما يعني صباح ما كانوا بيعرفوا اذا
لبنانيه ولا مصريه ولا فريد الاطرش يعني
نسمي ما بنخلص يعني في عدد كبير من النجوم
العرب اللي اشتغلوا بمصر ونجحوا وحققوا
ذاتهم حتى المصريين ما بيعرفوا شو جنسيته
الحقيقي النجوم العرب المتواجدين في
الدراما المصريه هذا العام الفنان السعودي
محمد القز اللي يشارك غاده عبد الرازق
بطوله مسلسل تلتي ثلاثه فرح بسيس هو خالد
القيش من سوريا امام خالد النبوي في رساله
الامام فريال يوسف من تونس امام سهير رمزي
في ليله ام البنات جهات سعد من سوريا امام
روجينا في ستهم وشمس الكويتيه امام كوكبه
من النجوم في سر ده بالنسبه لي حلم يعني
اي فنان في الوطن العربي بيحب يشتغل في
مصر ده تحدي وده نعمه وده حاجه جميله جدا
انك تقدم نفسك للجمهور المصري اللي هو انا
اعتبره من اصعب الجماهير الفنيه الموجوده
في الوطن العربي لانه جمهور ناقد اللهجه
اصلا في حياه العاديه بتشكل مشكله فانا
بتكلم تلات لهجات في جمله واحده يعني
احيانا نتكلم سعودي بعد ثواني اقلب مصري
بعدين سوري بعدين بس اللهجه المصريه
انا عندي تحدي هنا اني الجمهور لو تقبل
الشخصيه مش هيدقق كتير
باهتمام فمن كانوا هؤلاء النجوم
[موسيقى]
الورقه فيها شويه الغاز حاولت احلها عن
طريق بحث